retour en france avec la voc desjardins
il ya quelques années la pelle et la
pioche était encore considérée comme
ringarde et bien c'est devenu maintenant
davantage qu'une mode
une façon de vivre y compris en ville et
la crise a encore accéléré le mouvement
le jardin secret des français c'est le
dossier de cette édition il est signé
perrine bonnet eric mézil
nous avons ici une belle plante une
blague quand ras les pâquerettes toute
la partie en fait des shows la rose est
très souvent et ça pousse ça pousse
blond mais ça peut pousser marron
sortant elie semoun ne plaisante pas
avec le jardinage il ne rate aucun salon
dévore les livres de bouteilles en fait
c'est cette une est cher ça c'est des
efforts ben du coup connais des plantes
au nom barbare ou qu'ils vendaient ça
j'en ai eu besoin c'est un besoin vital
et je comprends que que dans la france
il ya une sorte de folie du jardinage
moi je considère que ce que c'est pas
ringard des mes plantes par un gars même
très tendance à la télé au supermarché
le jardin fait carton plein en cinq ans
les ventes ont grimpé de 23% chiffre
d'affaires plus de 6 milliards d'euros
un foyer sur deux est doté d'un jardinet
une vague verte qui déferle sur le béton
va les limaces travail au milieu des
tours mais à déménager en banlieue pour
ce tout petit bout de terrain qu'est ce
qui a poussé là de quoi s'occuper de ses
oignons et enseigné à erwan cinq ans la
valeur de la terre apprendre la patience
apprendre les gestes qu'il faut faire
tous les jours et que finalement on
récolte des choses que quand il ya un
peu d'effort et pas quand c'est une fois
là c'est pas juste dans le magasin dans
une conserve et là c'est génial on ces
nouveaux jardiniers sont des novices qui
peuvent se décourager au premier a dit
oui n'est pas gros raté
ou miser sur l'entr'aide les jardins
partagés germe dans toutes les grandes
villes
il en existe mille 500 en france ici des
terrasses au coeur d'une cité hlm de
paris ouverte aux habitants du quartier
si on n'a pas vraiment les pieds à terre
mais on a vu ma honte voilà on a des
souvenirs chacun deux grands parents la
campagne de parents enfin de jardin
ce bijou dans son enfant la moitié basse
que moitié landais toujours connu la
terre le retour à la terre philippe
colle y croit tellement qu'il a changé
de métier c'est la première phrase des
bois je n'avais pas encore noté sur le
site
cet ancien journaliste a investi tout
son argent dans un site internet dédié
aux jardiniers des conseils des échanges
de graines en deux mois déjà plus de
2000 connectés de nouvelles tendances
aujourd'hui qui apparaît ce qui est
toujours plus de jardins naturels où on
a envie de redécouvrir aujourd'hui ce
que faisaient nos parents jusque jusque
dans les années 70 comme comment il
jardinait avec les trucs d'ancien avec
tout ça on a besoin à nouveau de le
redécouvrir et de l'échangé lentement
mais sûrement la tendance creuse son
sillon 60 % des plus de 20 ans aspire à
se nourrir du jardin comme michelle
obama qui a planté pour les repas de la
maison blanche du chou du romarin mais
pas de betteraves son mari les déteste